[Musique]
bienvenue sur le plateau dathané dates à
retenir on va passer toute cette
émission avec stéphane koch l'un vous
êtes journaliste chroniqueur musical
biographe romancier et vous publier
l'histoire secrète de la conquête de
l'espace aux éditions du rocher et l'on
commence tout de suite par l'image que
vous avez choisie pour illustrer notre
époque
une panthère une panthère des neiges ce
que j'ai beaucoup aimé le livre de
sylvain tesson et a rien de plus beau
que la quête de l'animal rares j'avais
lu moby dick quand j'étais jeune et donc
sylvain tesson décrit ce mélange de
muscler dassier ce mouvement parfait ce
qui est un peu la fusée finalement petit
peu le symbole de la fusée et j'ai du
mal à me résoudre à l'idée qu'on ne
verra plus ces grands fauves dans les
cirques donc il ya un paradoxe entre le
désir de les voir libres de voir
gambader comme ça et de ne pas les voir
enfermé un temps le regret que de ne
plus les voir qu'en photo parce que
c'est des êtres rares et exceptionnelles
et je trouve que ce questionnement est
tout à fait de notre époque c'est à dire
qu'on regrette de ne pas avoir la rareté
comme ça un petit peu dans un bocal et
en même temps des contents de la voir un
petit peu c'est gagner c'est s'échapper
dans la nature mais c'est le paradoxe là
que je voulais exprimer il est
impossible de la voir dans la capture
photo on voit bien des guépards des
lions mais en vox il l'interrompt il met
tout un livre à le voir et à un suspense
va-t-il réussir à voir alors il ya tout
un jeune de la poésie qui se met en
marche il ya des magnifiques pages et
tous à chaque fois au détour d'une page
de chaque page on croit qu'il va l'avoir
puis finalement le bon il la verra un
peu comme ça dans une ombre et c'est et
c'est assez fabuleux quoi évidemment il
la voit pas parce que appartement c'est
un peu comme les films de jacques
tourneur oui les films fantastiques
quand on voit le monstre l'animal
fabuleux on est déçu alors que quand on
le voit pas le rêve l'imaginaire
fonctionne à plein et bien commençons
[Musique]
votre histoire secrète de la conquête
spatiale commence avec nicolas guibal
chiche l'un des assassins du tsar
alexandre ii en 1981 c'était artificiers
du groupe il avait 27 ans il a été
condamné à mort et exécuté
mais pendant son séjour en prison c'est
lui qui a accompli dites-vous le premier
pas de l'ère spatiale oui parce qu'en
fait il disait d'ailleurs si j'avais
vécu dans un autre endroit sous un autre
régime au lieu de faire des bombes pour
tuer le 2 ça j'aurais fait des machines
merveilleuses fabuleuse et donc qu'ils
regrettaient quelqu'un de très bons en
artif isr il s'occupait dans son petit
village des feux d'artifice et un
artificier de gigny et c'est lui qui a
confectionné les bombes au lieu d'aller
vers la science vers la technique et ben
il a rejoint ses grandes rousses et
groupe arnault anarchique qui
pullulaient comme ça en russie impériale
en 1881 dans ce groupe qui s'appelait la
volonté du peuple menée par une certaine
sophie à petrov sky à petit une
activiste anarchistes et ils ont
assassiné le tsar alexandre 2 est en
fait il a pendant sa dépendance à bhl
son séjour en prison il a confectionné
une fusée sur laquelle qui peut tout
toutes les recherches sont se sont basés
se sont fondés et on peut dire que c'est
le vrai inventeur de la conquête
spatiale et demandé à ses bureaux ainsi
bourreau bourreau un petit peu les six
mois un peu de temps et que je finisse
mon travail et les bourreaux ne l'ont
pas laissé le temps évidemment ils ont
pendu deux manières il a été très
courageux et après ces dessins sont
tarés sont allés dans les archives et on
moisi pendant des années dans des dans
un tiroir du secrétariat d'un
secrétariat quelconque et c'est vraiment
des années après grâce à constantin
tsiolkovski qui est un qui était un
vieux prophète qui lui aussi dans son
coin dessiner des fusées puis il la
révolution de 1917 que le génie de cet
inventeur criminel parce qu'il faut dire
pour dire comme il l'est un inventaire
criminelle a réussi à exploser seul kf
ce qui viole qu'au losc ciolkowski sept
convois la constante et d'un lui c'est
le père de l'astronautique moderne il
est donc contemporain de 2
de nicolay c'est le fils d'un garde
forestier il est né en 1857 et lui va
tenter d'améliorer le la machine volante
de l'assassin vie le gros problème
auquel ils se confrontent lui sait
comment est-ce qu'on peut s'arracher à
l'attraction terrestre bah oui c'est bon
on peut aller dans l'atmosphère le vrai
problème d'ailleurs souvent plus on
l'appelle l'archimède russe a fait
savoir qu'il était sourd d'une oreille
oscillé dans son monde il était coupé un
petit peu de son nom parce qu'il a vu la
scarlatine une maladie assez courante à
l'époque donc du coup il était dans sa
chambre sans fin sur macd et délivre
degano des livres qui l'a qu'il
empruntait à son père qu'elle adorait
l'astronomie aussi et on est et on est
un petit peu dans la russie du cosim
isme d'une la théosophie cette espèce de
mélange de spiritualité de religion au
puits de science on pense que là la
survie de l'homme passera par là le
cosmos et alors on pense que l'homme
c'est dieu lui-même l'homme et dieu en
fait et donc pas comme il est dieu il
peut changer finalement là là là le
destin de l'humanité en conquérant le
cosmos est ce effectivement on voit
d'ailleurs dans les dessins qu'on a
trouvées dans ses archives des
magnifiques avions en métal avec
structure métallique il avait inventé
aussi un dirigeable de faire on voit
d'ailleurs les premiers avions des
frères wright en 1903 c'est des avions
en toile vraiment assez minable et lui
il avait dans ses archives déjà des
avions complètement moderne qui rappelle
d'ailleurs le furtif le lac de van à
ventre à bien des années après qu'ils
n'ont jamais volé il avait dans ses six
et là qu'il fallait d'abord utilisé le
métal et qui va les utiliser des
appareils extrêmement extrêmement
sophistiqués et des et des propulsions
capable d'arracher un plus jour un plus
un plus lourd que l'air dans
l'attraction terrestre et le troisième
complicité de la belle époque c'est
yaakov perelman du sein prof de maths et
de physique un vulgarisateur de génie un
grand écrivain un grand écrivain qui lui
parce que c'est très important aussi
ceux qui ont pu convaincre le peuple
russe qu'il fallait vraiment se
consacrer à à la conquête spatiale parce
qu'évidemment dans en 1880 du 185
temples et des travaux de console comme
s'ils ne sont pas pris au sérieux faudra
attendre vraiment la révolution de 1910
on apprend que la révolution d'octobre
va leur être bénéfique à pleine vie
simplement parce que c'est le changement
de dumontier le monde d'avant où le
monde d'après voyez c'est donc donc du
coup qu'ont certains souhaitent que ce
qui va être va être reçue dans le par
les hautes sphères du pouvoir il va
recevoir des financements il aura déjà
accompli tout son honneur et perelman va
pouvoir aussi écrire des textes qui vont
convaincre les russes finalement de se
consacrer à il aura évidemment une à
destin tragique le pauvre sait qu'il va
mourir pendant le siège de leningrad de
faim de il va être affamés dans les
allemands vont voulu tuer avec quelques
autres grands grands spécialistes et
grands ce grand esprit scientifique
russe et le quatrième on peut dire que
celle sergueï korolev mais lui c'est un
peu plus tard korolev c'est le fondateur
du programme spatial soviétique c'était
un pilote au départ on le voit la
relève s'est il va profiter au fond de
l'enseignement aéronautique qui est le
meilleur à l'époque au monde c'est celui
de l'union soviétique c'est le suisse
union soviétique en plus il y avait
évidemment des mdd parade aérienne 1 et
à un moment donné il va voir sergei
touch king keitel grands pilotes de
l'époque et regarde ça il est fasciné
effectivement à partir de là il ne rêve
que de monter dans un avion dans les
planeurs et dans toutes les écoles les
profs bricole eux mêmes leur planeur et
vol s'il ya une passion une vraie
passion aérienne et sergueï korolev va
toute sa vie essayez finalement de de
monter dans des hydravions de monter
dans des avions de construire lui-même
des aéroplanes il va avoir un vrai
problème parce que évidemment çà çà çà
çà çà çà leur portée par un petit peu
les grandes purges staliniennes et ils
vendent des deux victimes se retrouvent
au goulag sa photo parce qu'à l'époque
il est au gris devait le great c'est un
il ya bien plusieurs organismes que
staline finances parce que c'est
évidemment les que l'économie ball chic
veulent vraiment développer la conquête
spatiale parce qu'ils pensent que
l'avenir de l'humanité passera par là et
donc il ya le ddd des associations comme
le grid fondée par plant fredrik sandler
qui malheureusement nous a très tôt de
la typhoïde et
sergueï korolev rentre-dedans parle par
une petite annonce dit je cherche des
esprits scientifiques pouvant comment
développer une fusée et là il répond il
va dans cette dans cette entreprise et
là il va évidemment mené une carrière
brillante avec michael tuga chelski
qu'était le général de l'armée rouge qui
lui y croit et quelques personnages qui
vont disparaître un par un jet ski
victime des mêmes sergueï korolev va
être arrêté tard que c'était truffé de
micros et qu' il y avait une paranoïa
absolument incroyable parce que tout le
monde tout le monde pensait que des
espions étaient partout et donc il le
parle à voix basse il y avait un vrai
une vraie paranoïa et sergueï korolev va
lui-même être arrêté et envoyé dans le
cible dans les camps de colima où il va
passer de l'ombre de nombreuses années
il va être battu toutes ses dents vont
sauter va être tabassés par des
policiers du nkvd et va passer quand
même dix ans presque dix ans dans la
souffrance la barre sans voir sa femme
ni sa fille et il va être relâché en 44
et les charges ne seront abandonnées que
dix ans plus tard en 57 quand un crouch
à la morgue après la mort de staline
quand khrouchtchev prendra le pouvoir
mais il aura toute sa vie il aura cette
espèce d'épée de damoclès sur la
structure la tête et ça va d'ailleurs
provoqué sa mort parce que quand tu es
en 66 leur un problème de santé toutes
les blessures qu'il aura reçu pendant
ces les mauvais traitements pendant son
séjour en sibérie vont causer sa mort en
66 korolev celui qui a lancé avec succès
la première fusée en urss c'était le 17
août 1933 mon prenons cgi r d 09 son nom
la voile à l'ird 0
c'est la toute première et c'est lui
aussi également qui est l origine
du spoutnik et de et du voyage de
gagarine en levant en photo avec
gagarine est ce qu'il ya
d'extraordinaire vous raconter que
korolev au moment où on envoie le
spoutnik au moment où gagarine va dans
l'espace personne ne sait qui relèvent
non parce que évidemment c'était très
mauvais pour l'union soviétique que le
héros de la conquête spatiale soit un
ancien rescapé du goulag donc du coup on
invente une homme de paille qui
s'appelle leonid seedorf et le 6/9 va
prendre les petits fours draguer des
femmes parcourir l'europe encore en
faisant croire que c'est lui l'inventeur
de ce public pendant ce temps comment la
pluie travail il y avait que ça est-ce
que ça n'est pas aussi que les russes à
ce moment là ont peur qu'on enlève
corless ya rien de garde l'accessible ya
ces lésions de la vence ya cette
question effectivement ils ont pu ils
ont peur qu'on assassine évidemment
parce qu'il ya une vraie une vraie
guerre froide lee s'est instauré entre
les états unis et l'union soviétique ils
veulent absolument pas d'ailleurs le le
baïkonour est
vraiment dedans dans un endroit secret
il ya des avions espions ils ont portes
d'avions espions dont il ya une espèce
de paranoïa qui s'est installée
évidemment très très très union
soviétique très cool très très
communiste en fait et donc ils préfèrent
cacher qu'on relève et finalement peu à
peu au moment de sa mort que la vraie
identité de korolev va être révélé au
russe l'équivalent de korolev mais côté
allemand c'est vers narbonne boum boum
boum il est né enfin je sais plus quand
il est d'aimer ou tous les ordinateurs
12 1912 c'est en 1938 qui fait qui lance
sa première petite fusée expérimentale
enfin il a 18 ans je croyais lewis est
un artificier aussi j'ai quelqu'un qui a
lu tous les grands grands parce que les
grands grands écrivains scientifiques
s'il hermano berthe allemand robert
goddard donc il il est gavé de de cette
littérature là effectivement il veut
aussi il veut aussi réussir à conquérir
et il est un peu au courant de ce que
commencent à faire les russes et
meilleur maintenant le problème c'est
qu'il claire arrive au pouvoir alors
qu'est ce que tu fais pour continuer ces
essais il obligé de prendre sa carte du
parti nazi conclure on lui reprochera
plus tard mais après il ya une espèce de
doute est il un vrai asie l'activé
acquis at il pris sa carte pour essayer
de continuer et de profiter des
financements parce que vous savoir qu'à
l'époque les nazis eux ils veulent tout
ils veulent de transformer votre
utiliser les bombes pour raser des
villes entières mais lui il est bon pour
lui une la boum c'est conquérir la lune
c'est conquérir les étoiles donc il ya
cette espèce de héguy korolev aura le
même problème cette espèce de dualité
entre si certains qui voulaient la
guerre et d'autres qui veulent conquérir
les premières fusées qui vont
fonctionner et dont celle que va
construire faire leurs mômes la fusée v2
c'est des missiles balistiques à celle
des missiles balistiques je vois les
membres sont des armes c'est des
missiles balistiques d'ailleurs un
moment donné himmler fait arrêter 23dans
44 parce qu'il le soupçonne de vouloir
au lieu de préparer des v2 de vouloir
préparer des fusées pour la lune en plus
d'être un espion au service de
l'angleterre donc il est arrêté pendant
pas mal de moi et c'est albert speer qui
va le libérer pascal bérubé est détesté
himmler dont il ministre de la
production de la prayelle qui était à
l'époque le miz la production
industrielle qui était aussi
d'architectes du rail et qui est gay et
qui était lui vit croyait aussi
discrètement mais il disait avant de
braun surtout ne dis pas que tu espères
conquérir la lune conquérir les étoiles
parce que tu risque la peine de mort un
moment donné il ya a failli les gays
exécuté von braun il était à deux doigts
de l'exécuter parce que mais il a hésité
parce qu'il voyait bien qu'à se bercent
pire était contré parc bat pas mal de
deux responsables nazis étaient contre
l'exécution devenu d'ailleurs la fusée
v2 entend fuser c'est génial mais en
tant qu'arme ça n'a aucun intérêt non
oui ça me sert strictement à rien les v2
en fait très peu de victimes voilà on
était beaucoup pour faire peur un
puisqu'il y avait un ronronnement
surtout le vin il ya un espèce d'une
espèce de ronronnement dans le ciel qui
terrifiait les populations anglaise mais
effectivement il ya eu très peu de
victimes c'était surtout une une arme
d'intox pour intoxiquer l'ennemi mais il
va se rendre aux américains on voit la
photo là il arrive arrive blessés ils
arrivent à échapper aux nazis dans les
derniers jours de la guerre il se rend
aux américains et c'est lui qui va
compter que construire la fusée saturn 5
qui va lancer la caméra il aura peu de
mal parce que les américains n'y croient
pas hésité à le faire travailler quand
même causé un ancien nazi eisenhower a
dit je veux surtout pas d'anciens nazis
sur mon territoire et finalement il cède
à denver en accueillant quelques
spécialistes parce qu'il comprend que
les russes commencent à prendre de
l'avancé donc isimat on va essayer quand
même donné de les faire travailler et
alors pendant pas mal de temps 23 ne
fait rien et il va être présentateur
pour walt disney trichomes
extraordinaire anne asic et présentateur
pour les émissions de walt disney sur
l'espace est bon et il essaie de
convaincre aussi les américains que
l'espace est formidable avant évidemment
de revenir un petit peu dans le giron
scientifique
il est absolument indispensable à la
conquête de la lune la fusée saturn 5
indispensable cccm qu'il en soit il est
indispensable à la conquête de la lune
et d'ailleurs c'est assez amusant parce
que on revient un peu en arrière il a vu
le film de fritz lang la femme sur la
lune un président un dans le grand
cinéma de berlin le palast un moment
donné c'est c'la parce que hermann aux
bears en était le conseiller et c'était
son idole herman aubert s'était lui
aussi il vous l'avez sur la lutte
d'ailleurs il va l'inviter en 69 une
invitation spéciale qui envoya human
anvers pour qu'ils assistent à ce grand
moment du dieu de l'envolée vers la lune
de neil amstrong et des deux autres
comment les comment les les astronautes
américains qui sont tous d'anciens
pilotes d'essai la plupart d'entre eux
ont fait la guerre plutôt dans le
pacifique mais il aurait pu la faire
contre contre les mêmes comment comment
étaient les rapports entre les
astronautes américains et werner von
braun très très distant on peut dire n'y
avait pas le même rapport carrez korolev
puisque korolev il avait un côté un peu
il était il avait des grosses colères et
il avait un côté charnel les vins très
proche de derrière et range très proche
d'ailleurs korolev nar a ramené tous ses
cosmonautes sur terre c'est un peu la
réputation qu'il avait 22 bronn c'était
un peu plus froid un peu plus glacée
parce que votre talent allemande et on
le voit dans les présentations de
télévision qu'il fait c'est quand même
quelqu'un qu'il ne rigole pas beaucoup
qui est très sombre et d'ailleurs
c'était comme ça que d'ailleurs qu'il
qu'ils obtenaient de la crédibilité
auprès des américains parce que c'était
l'allemand sérieux l'allemand froid les
allemands glacée qui faisait peur aux
gens mais finalement c'était le meilleur
allemand le mais la berd personne pour
nous pour emmener les gens un petit peu
dans l'espace et là
la première fusée russe en 1947 elle
était inspirée elle aussi de la fusée v2
puisque les russes faisaient travailler
le muguet truc le lieutenant de faire
d'abord et xian adragna boris tchertok
aussi monsieur quand de paint moon donc
la base où nous était lancé dv2 sur
l'île 12 d'hommes a été prise par les
russes évidemment ils ont envoyé korolev
ils ont envoyé boris tchertok vise en
fait à peu près tous les grands noms de
deux russes pour étudier un petit peu ce
qu'ils pouvaient trouver et il y avait
une espèce de course alalala capture un
petit peu d éléments du v2 et ils en ont
rappelé leur rapporter pas mal mais les
américains aussi donc il s'est vraiment
le le cadavre de dvd a été un petit peu
c'est arachides des vieux trucs vous
raconterez oui c'est ça le truc plus
vous raconter que lui il veut terminer
avec les russes il veut pas aller aux
états unis ils vont rester en allemagne
voilà et ils préfèrent travailler que
voilà parce qu'il a sa famille parce
qu'il veut il veut être tranquille il
n'a pas envie de travail pour les
américains il n'est pas forcément
communiste un peu mais on peut pas dire
ça mais c'est plat la russie il offre
des conditions de travail beaucoup plus
proche de ce qu'il vivait pendant
pendant là le régime hitlérien donc ils
le valent d'ailleurs sa femme va va
faire un journal de bord où elle raconte
un petit peu la vie sur l'île sur comme
ça avec les avec les avec les russes et
il va travailler pour que relève est
donc en 1957 spoutnik tourne autour de
la terre le nom de korolev n'apparaît
pas vous avez expliqué pourquoi c'est
pour ça aussi qu'il aura pas le prix
nobel il aurait eu le prix nobel il
aurait dû la voir
et
spoutnik 2 20 ans portait une petite
chienne laïka qui va faire pleurer le
monde entier oui alors moi je non pas
que je me souvienne de leica quand elle
était dans l'espace mais mais je
connaissais évidemment aux anges non et
j'en étais encore rester l'histoire
qu'on nous a raconté à l'époque à savoir
que elle était partie que tout le monde
était très malheureux qu'elle parte
parce que il savait qu'il ya peu de
chances qu'elle revienne il y en avait
aucune d'ailleurs mais on avait raconté
à l'époque qu'elle avait survécu pendant
plusieurs jours et vous dit en fait pas
du tout non elle est morte tout de suite
très vite très vite elle a été brûlée
vive très vite et finalement la fusée le
pouce boutique à tourner des jours avec
un cadavre de chienne à l'intérieur
alors qu'on disait même à tout le monde
qu'elle était toujours violent de
l'agent stas racontait un jeu tout va
bien on a vu là la petite chienne a on
entend sa respiration tout va bien en
fait elle était déjà morte parce que ça
c'est on est en plein mensonge la du de
la coupe de la propagande soviétique
effectivement et en plus il y avait des
les mouvements de la spa les mouvements
propres aux animaux et tout était
furieux ils envoyaient des tas de
lettres à l'ambassade d'union soviétique
même korolev était ému parce qu'il
savait qu'elle ne reviendrait pas il ya
eu une vraie émotion autour de cette
petite chaîne ne sait pas on en a envoyé
beaucoup des animaux une action non rien
mais cette chaîne là elle avait quelque
chose parce qu'il l'avait ramassée dans
les poubelles de moscou et elle avait un
regard comme si elle comprenait ce qui
allait lui arriver est allé tester une
chaîne très intelligente et alors on
avait annoncé qu' elle étai elle avait
été étonné juillet parce que moment de
rentrer dans l'atmosphère elle l est est
ce qu'ils avaient c'était ce qu'il avait
dit ce qu'ils avaient prévu de
l'euthanasie mais c'était un mensonge
vous n'avez rien prévu du tout il avait
dit on lui a prévu de la nourriture
empoisonnée qu elle mangera un moment
donné tout et tout et tout est surveillé
tout et tout fonctionnera en fonctions
de l'ordinateur un moment donné quand on
pourra plus la ramener elle mangera leno
la nourriture empoisonnée elle mourra en
fait c'était faux il a appuyé n'ont pas
de nourriture empoisonnée ils n'avaient
rien prévu pour pour abréger ses
souffrances ça a été un mensonge eux
mais surtout une émotion terrible
l'époque
on dit toujours que maintenant les gens
sont sont très amoureux des animaux il
adore les animaux mais à l'époque déjà
il y avait des associations pro ni pro
animalière qui était très puissante et
qui était furieuse qu'on sacrifie un
animal comme ça pour selon les gens le
un plaisir un plaisir humains petit peu
futile oui c'était ce que certains
faussaires
os x games alors gagarine la ccl
l'événement absolument incroyable
il va tourner pendant combien de temps
au tour de la terre ou très peu chez
chaque jour dans très peu de temps une
heure une heure ou une heure ou une
heure
et il en faudra compter que le le
spoutnik tombe il se retrouve au milieu
des champs oui personne ne sait où il
est
il chercha téléphone prise admire encore
un couplet est là elle a été interviewée
maintes fois et en plus il avait une
tenue un peu comme un extraterrestre une
tenue orange et il n'avait pas dit il à
il tombe dans le champ et d'ailleurs on
dit que le père de gagarine aurait pris
à une carriole à cheval pour se
précipiter vers moscou pour aller
embrasser son fils vit il cette espèce
de confrontation entre le monde agricole
médiévale qui était encore la russie à
l'union soviétique à cette époque et le
et le monde futuriste de baïkonour avec
dédé des cosmonautes hyper entraînés et
des fusées et les autres pandas les
images 2d
ensuite des capsules américaines qui
tombe dans l'océan il ya les
hélicoptères y arrive tout de suite pour
ouvrir le lan on l'a bien tous n'avaient
rien prévu il n'a rien gagné mais même
valentina che que kovalchuk est la
suivante aussi à dériver elle est aussi
à la hausse il est aussi tombé en plein
milieu de la nuit elle a aussi été
recueillis dans des dents des dents des
dans une maison de deux paysans c'était
pareil on ne savait pas c'était vraiment
tout nouveau on ne savait pas comment
les récupérer après dix ans plus tard
évidemment avec les américains déjà une
co et vous y voit plus que les russes
ont fait donc déjà il améliore un petit
peu la manière de réceptionner ces
fusées way et avant valentine en restant
un moment sur youri gagarine parce qu'il
est quand même assez extraordinaire sa
célébrité planétaire il va faire
d'ailleurs une tournée mondiale d'avenir
en france nous raconter il va il va
absolument partout il est absolument
être du lait partout les enfants par
tout le monde et il meurt bêtement à 34
ans oui dans un avion avec un pilote
qu'en fait il avait plu à piloter
évidemment puisque ont voulu garder
c'était le héros donc il souffrait de
saïda il aurait aimé reprendre un petit
pc relève qui lui avait dit tu ne
voleras plus tu ne voleras encore neuf
le visu ne volera plus est d'ailleurs
clair y allait de l'histoire dramatique
de comme armor associant 67 ce
cosmonaute qui finalement a pris la
place de gagarine il savait très bien
qu'il allait mourir et il voulait pas
donner leur redonner à la place de
quitter par lâcheté sa place parce
qu'ils savaient que gagarine l'apprendre
est parce qu il était courageux il
n'avait peur de rien et donc du coup bas
gagarine ne remontera plus dans un
vaisseau spatial et même dans des avions
c'est dire qu'elle à cet avion il a la
chance avec seryoguine qui est un ancien
pilote de la guerre de 40 qui dit parce
qu'il est obligé de monter avec un
instructeur il ne peut pas monter tout
seul et là il a il est plus là il est
content il monte dans un dans cet avion
est là l'avion va disparaître au moment
où il probablement y tenaient les
commandes et on sait pas très bien ce
qui s'est passé on sait pas si c'est un
autre avion qui était dans le coin avec
des turbulences qui aurait déséquilibré
l'avion de gagarine on ne sait on ne
sait pas du tout il ya un mystère
beaucoup de gens pensent qu'il a été
assassiné que sa couche de la lettre
qu'il aurait écrite un peu pour
protester contre la mort de komarov il
aurait été assassiné par le kgb mais ça
rien n'est sûr que c'est toujours un
petit peu les fantasmes qu'on veut sur
une mort quand même une expliquer encore
et et puis à valentina donc est la
première femme à voler dans l'espace en
53 ans 63 et qui elle est une ouvrière
gagarine c'était un pilote comme le
seront les astronautes américains tous
des pilotes d'essai là ils choisissent
une ouvrière ça c'était mais gagne aussi
1 était un manqué d'instructions c'était
pas un intellectuel non plus les russes
vous voulez vraiment choisir des gens de
l'année de la condition la plus modeste
pour montrer la finalement là la place
la performance du monde ouvrier dans
l'espace effectivement elle l était l
usine et elle a répondu à une petite
annonce et elle est passée devant des
profs d'anglais de vendée des
intellectuels dans des bourgeois et elle
a été choisie par ce qui vient moelleux
correspondait mieux à ce que l'union
soviétique vous voulez un petit peu
m'ont démontré est en fête et ils ont
même fait un mariage bidon avec andrien
nikolaïev qu'était un autre un autre
cosmonautes mais qui était un mariage
complètement arrangé et elle a été
vraiment a servi de vitrine un petit peu
la propagande et locatifs ont raconté
que son vol à elle se passe très très
mal oui ceux de voiture il ya plein
d'incidents techniques et quand il ya
plein d'incidents techniques et des
erreurs plus ou moins fait par la base
et quand elle descend korolev lui dit
surtout tu ne dis rien tu fais comme si
tout se passait bien comme si ça me
levant l âme était parfait et donc à la
hausse revel accepté de se taire pendant
des deux d'accepter que l'on met les
erreurs de navigation sur ce pont fut
alors que c'était pas du tout elle et
elle est toujours vivant en algérie
pendant lé 10 pts député à la douma
d'ailleurs assez pro poutine parce
qu'évidemment elle justifie un peu près
toute la politique de poutine elle a
toujours été dans les rats il est
toujours été une serviteuse absolument
impeccable de des gouvernements qui se
sont succédés où on fait une pause
stéphane koch là on se retrouve juste
après
[Musique]
nous sommes toujours avec stéphane koch
l'un qui publie une histoire secrète de
la conquête spatiale aux éditions du
rocher tout ce que vous nous racontez là
c'est pas secret ça l'a été mais ça
l'est plus aujourd'hui il manquerait
plus que ça pourrait être une histoire
des secrets de la conquête spatiale en
fait mais c'est toujours pareil c'est à
dire qu'il ya déjà des oyats vous avez
dit tout à l'heure que les cas vous ne
saviez vous aviez oublié vous ne saviez
pas qu'elle était morte tout de suite
voilà ça c'est quand même un secret que
qui reste quand même très très qui a été
bien gardé a été bien gardé que les gens
croient encore voyez qu effectivement
c'est des secrets c'est très difficile
de trouver des vrais secrets mais il ya
encore des zones cachées comptant un
tueur comme ce qui est un personnage
secret nicolaï qui bâtissent et aussi
des personnages secrets qui bat chip ça
c'est sûr très peu de gens savent que
l'un des assassins de 12 heures
alexandre 2 dans sa cellule dessinée
pratiquement la preuve première mais
plus de gens savent que la conquête
spatiale commence en 1881 finalement
âgées les gens m'ont dit mais tu tues
quoi tu remontes en 1958 banon la
conquête spatiale ça commence au temps
des tsars et voilà et au fond et jules
verne a servi de 2,2 presque
d'aspirateur à nombre d'entre eux
d'ailleurs oui de la terre à la lune
donc publié en 1865 effectivement a
inspiré beaucoup beaucoup de deux
scientifiques d'écrivains scientifique
constantin tsiolkovski nicolas guibal
chiche sergueï korolev tout ce qu'on lui
jules verne et c'était vraiment un
auteur très très importante qu'il doit
être traité traduit un peu dans toutes
les langues il avait bu il était très
populaire et donc effectivement après
agi wells aussi way et qui a aussi écrit
des livres un petit peu d'anticipation
sur la lune sur la vie du voilier donc
vous raconter déjà qu'il est reçu par
staline douala et lénine mais il est
reçu par lénine dans les années 20 parce
qu'ils étaient remis avec gorki qu'il a
rangé ses 2 et 2 moi je l'aimé parce que
ce livre là cette histoire là se double
aussi d'une discussion politique sur le
monde d'après sur ce que doit être
l'humanité en fait et quand hadji wells
rencontre staline et lénine il veut
discuter un petit peu de ce que staline
veut faire d'eux des projets pour
l'avenir un petit peu et donc je pense
que là la conquête spatiale est aussi la
la la la quête d'un nouveau monde d'une
nouvelle société humaine d'une nouvelle
justice humaine et donc c'est là c'est
ce que aj ouest vient discuter dans le
bureau de de lénine puis de staline à ce
moment-là il servit évidemment pas de
quel crime se rend non se rend coupable
staline dont ils s'épargnent et est-ce
que staline va encourager la conquête
spatiale ou est-ce qu'il va encourager
les missiles balistiques
alors il ya un moment donné il encourage
la conquête spatiale et à man 2 il
engage les missiles balistiques c'est
dire que dans les années 30 qu'il
encourage plutôt la bande et spatiales
pire évidemment la guerre froide étant
ce qu'elle est en 45 il ya vraiment ils
s'opposent aux états unis donc à ce
moment là il commence à vouloir
orienter un petit peu les recherches
vers les missiles balistiques parce
qu'il sent que les délits sont une vraie
menace et c'est à ce moment là où
korolev et les autres ingénieurs vont
devoir un petit peu rusé slalomer pour
essayer de convaincre quand même le
pouvoir soviétique de continuer la
recherche spatiale mais il faut bien se
rend compte que quand pour la première
fois le spoutnik tourne autour de nos
têtes en 1957 pour les américains c'est
un cauchemar spoutnik ça la taille d'une
bombe oui c'est à dire que c'est une
menace considérable c'est les russes
sont capables d'envoyer spoutnik en
orbite ils sont capables d'envoyer une
bombe sur les états unis j'ai ce que les
harraga envir pas pensé mais et nos
erreurs au début ils rigolent ils
pensent que c'est un ballon de gonfler
avec du gaz de une bêtise mais il va
vite comprendre que c'est pas une bêtise
c'est à dire que c'est à ce moment là où
il va créer la nasa voyez ss - vous
vraiment ils organisent ils lancent le
la conquête spatiale en créant la nasa
en commençant à sélectionner des
astronautes donc il va comprendre vite
que victimes en les soviétiques là ne
plaisante plus et que le ballon ridicule
qui tourne autour de la tête c'est pas
un ballon c'est vraiment une machine une
machine infernale on parlait de
valentina la première femme dans dans
l'espace vous raconter l'histoire aussi
de jacqueline bécane
qu'on va voir cochrane cochrane de damon
cochrane qu'on peut voir en en photo
racontez là l'histoire de jacqueline
cochrane et l'histoire à la fois de
l'escadron de l'amour et de ceux et de
ces femmes recrutées par la nasa alors
j'ai raconté cette histoire quelle
histoire d'un échec finalement parce que
c'était une histoire qui ne va pas
aboutir mais la conquête spatiale c'est
aussi l'histoire des échecs
effectivement les les soviétiques se
vante se vanteront souvent d'être fait
plus féministe que les américains
verizon un communiste ils sont
progressistes et ils trouvent que les
américains sont vraiment macho donc du
coup ils vont essayer des américains
vont essayer finalement de lancer un
équipage qui s'appellerait mercury 13 et
le vous il faut le faire avec des ancien
pilote de chasse dont la fameuse
jacqueline cochrane qui était une
ancienne vendeuse de cosmétiques
qu'avait épouser un milliardaire fleuve
aude loum et le milliardaire ni pourquoi
tu ne ferais pas de la pub pour des
cosmétiques avec un avion s à ce moment
là où elle passe son brevet de pilote et
elle va devenir elle va chasser les
records et de maintenir une très grande
pilote de deux jets comme ça dans les
eaux des premiers jets et elle va
finalement être une une conquérir un
petit peu l'espace aéronautique et peu à
peu elle va organiser un petit peu
autour d'elle générer autour d'elle des
deux pilotes féminines pour essayer de
monter un petit peu un groupe capable
d'aller conquérir aller pendant la
guerre on se souvient que les russes
qu'il ya des femmes pilotes hors russie
m sawiris en rien les sorcières
l'essentiel des as c'est qu'avec sur des
héroïnes de l'union soviétique
les américaines il ya il ya un escadron
il ya un escadron et un escadron mais le
ce cadre on il va être créée dans les
années 40 et après il va y avoir une
espèce de blackout dessus parce qu'il y
aura beaucoup de morts est en fait on
leur a donné des avions assez pourri et
donc ayant un secret qui va un petit peu
plombé enveloppé un petit peu cette
expérience très très brève d'un escadron
de chasse est en fait c'étaient des vies
penser que les femmes pouvaient servir
pouvait piloter des avions de transport
des avions d'ambulances mais jacqueline
cochrane elle elle était contre google
et que les fans pilotes des avions de
chasse elle pensait que les femmes
n'étaient pas capables de piloter des
avions de chasse qu'il fallait il
laisser ça aux hommes mais par contre si
le piloter des avions de transport et
des avions bill ans elle pouvait
finalement de laisser les hommes est en
net recul d'hommes dans la violence dans
l'aviation de chasse comme ça qu'elle
pensait et puis finalement à partir de
des années 40 elle commence à se dire
qu'elle pourrait et qui pour elle
pourrait aller finalement dans la lune
aller conquérir un peu l'espace lézard
mais alors cette histoire de la nasa
recrutant des femmes ça a été l'objet de
beaucoup de polémiques autour de 2
d'hillary clinton qui avait raconté que
quand elle était enfant elle avait écrit
à la nasa pour devenir elle aussi
astronautes à kong a répondu que c'était
n'importe quoi que l avait jamais écrit
ni rien et que la nasa n'avait jamais
recruté deux femmes et puis a eu toute
une enquête et finalement certaines ont
dit mais moi aussi j'ai écrit et j'ai
reçu la même lettre qu hillary clinton à
savoir nous n'engageons pas de femmes
oui j'ai publié une lettre d'ailleurs du
11 mars avait beaucoup évidemment parce
que quand on a commencé à parler de la
conquête spatiale et a plein de filles
qui dit pourquoi pas moi et finalement
elle recevait des lettres un petit peu
cheap un début et lettre-type il est
pourtant elle à un moment la nasa il ya
pensé un moment il a nasa ya pensé mais
c'est plus une initiative individuelle
avec le docteur love laisse alors la
docteure le laisse lui il expérimente le
premier masque à oxygène parce qu'il
pense que bientôt même les avions de
ligne vont aller dans la stratosphère
vont vous quittez un petit peu
l'atmosphère et quand on aura besoin de
masques à oxygène et c'est jacqueline
cochrane qui va en essayez donc déjà il
expérimente de leur moteur de leur côté
un petit peu une de leur côté la lauter
les hautes altitudes et l'oeuvre je
pense que la conquête spatiale passera
par la médecine et donc ils créent dans
sa clinique d'albuquerque ddd des
conditions pour améliorer
l'oxygène il pour améliorer le lait les
tenues des détenus des causes des futurs
astronautes et c'est comme ça que peu à
peu finalement les médias caveau y
croire il faut financer la clinique de
docteur lovelace mais au début c'est lui
même qui la financent parce que personne
n'y croit mais c'est comme ça si sa part
qu'une saisie totalement individuel et
les américains vous finir par financer
cette clinique et par y croire un peu
plus jusqu'au moment où il y aura donc
les entraînements qui ont qu'ils
organiseront dans le nouveau mexique
avec le docteur lovelace jacqueline
cochrane plein plein de dents une
certaine luo li fang qu'on a retrouvée
qui était une des jeunes qui devaient
normalement monter dans mercury 13 et
qui vient de là de de s'envoler avec
elon musk coucher plus richard branson
l'inde et des milliardaires qui conquit
conquiert main dans l'espace elle a 85
ans la toute sa vie rêvée d'astronautes
elle a été très déçu quand le programme
mercury 13 a été arrêté à brax été aboli
en 1910 à 160 ou 1961 et là elle a enfin
pu monter soixante dix ans après danse
dans une capsule et connaître enfin son
rêve de l'espace devrait donc c'est une
histoire assez belle quand même d'un
échec mais qui finalement une femme ak à
l'âge de 84 ans va réussir à conquérir
un peu les étoiles une américaine qui a
joué un rôle dans la conquête de
l'espace c'est catherine johnson
qui était une mathématicienne noir
donc on a appris à connaître depuis
grâce au film les figures de l'ombre
alors catherine johnson l on lui doit
quoi ah ben on lui doit simplement
quelle est celle qui a piloté alan
shepard en 61 parce qu'elle était très
bonne en mathématiques c'est le premier
rang le premier premier américain dans
l'espace dans l'espace donc elle l'a
elle la pile est l'équivalent gagarine
quelques exactement donc elle à elle a
elle été une génie des mathématiques
manger j'ai lu ses mémoires c'est assez
beau parce qu'elle raconte un petit peu
la série gassion et en même temps quand
elles arrivent se présente comme ça un
peu au débotté on lui dit non on a déjà
notre quota de noir donc elle insisté
finalement elle finit par être engagée
et elle a une patronne quesnoy rossi et
donc c'est on les appelait les
ordinateurs en jupe tellement les essais
organisations chargées évidemment parce
que on commence les les ordinateurs ibm
commencent à arriver un petit peu tout
doucement dans le milieu aéronautique
mais on a besoin quand même d'un facteur
humain très très brillant pour refaire
les calculs parce qu'ils n'ont pas
totalement confiance dans les
ordinateurs et elle sera l'une des
grandes calculatrice qui va rare on dit
qu'elle a sauvé par exemple apollo 13
quand ils ont vu leurs problèmes
techniques elle va toute sa vie john
glenn je crois que john glenn quand il
part après après alan shepard il veut
absolument qu'elles soient là
il dit dis quand même moins elle est
noire c'est une femme mais si elle fait
des bons calculs je veux bien donc parce
qu'ils étaient des machos les la plupart
ils voulaient pas que des femmes partent
gagarine john glenn voulait pas que des
mères de familles partent là où ils
étaient ils supportaient pas ils étaient
d'accord pour des femmes partent mais
célibataire n'est pas des mers pas des
mamans pas des mères de famille donc il
avait un côté quand même assez macho et
finalement john glenn va accepter parce
que john glenn fait un peu la pluie et
le beau temps dans le milieu de la nasa
et donc il va dire moi y'a aucun
problème si elle est bonne en calcul je
vous fais confiance il va partir comme
ça est ce que comme dans le film les
figures de l'ombre la ségrégation à la
nasa était telle qu on la montre à ce
moment là avec des femmes qui sont
obligées de marcher oui
300 mètres pour aller dans des toilettes
réservées aux couleurs manger dans les
cantines séparés et alors elle raconte
dans ses mémoires karine delaune ça ne
la jette ça ne la dérange pas parce que
d'abord lé seul dans son bureau souvent
et elle rentre très tard le soir son
mari va mourir assez tôt la nuit assez
compliquée et elle et elle est vraiment
l cook se consacre corps et âme à ces
chiffres ces calculs elle va ne vit pas
donc elle ne vit pas dans le pays où
elle est donc finalement la ségrégation
ne se rend pas bien compte parce qu'elle
vit dans les étoiles elle est tout le
temps toute la journée de 7 heures du
matin jusqu'à minuit à refaire les
calculs avec une angoisse et évidemment
on peut le comprendre de se tromper donc
elle va vivre comme ça comme un robot
pendant pas mal d'années en 1969 donc
armstrong et aldrin sont restées 2h30
sur la lune et y ont déposé plusieurs
emblème vous le dites dont deux
médailles à l'éffigie de deux russes qui
était mort à ce moment-là gagarine et
komarov oui oui il y aura ces emblèmes
là parce qu'évidemment la montre qu'il
ya une espèce de solidarité entre les
russes et les américains pour les
astronomes voilà bah oui parce qu'enfin
ils voyaient ça comme un symbole de la
réconciliation des deux blocs parce que
voilà le rêve de des russes que les
russes rêvait aussi de d'aller sur la
lune ils n'ont jamais pu parce que leurs
fusils étaient trop lourdes parce
qu'évidemment avec les leurs problèmes
politiques khrouchtchev n'y croyais pas
staline n'y croyais pas vraiment donc
ils ont pris alors qu'il avait pris un
retard décisif sur la conquête lunaire
et les américains donc ce avec qu' il y
avait eu des morts en union soviétique
donc il voulait réconcilier il ya une
autre pièce que ni la faune à poser
c'est un bout de l'avion des frères
wright les premiers vols en 1903 il a
demandé la permission au musée
d'emporter un bout de fuselage et il la
pause est là haut parce qu'évidemment
c'était toute l'histoire de l'aviation
qui étaient récompensés avec 7 cette
année ni sage on pense jamais au
troisième qui lui pendant que les deux
marchent sur l une est la seule personne
sur terre qui ne qui ne voit pas ce qui
se passe c'est le troisième et qui reste
dans le noir il reste dans le noir dans
une silence et noir pas de radio rien
cependant si les deux autres vont
rentrer je pense que c'est là c'est le
plus angoissant ont cessé la terreur
enfantine du noir il a vécu et en plus
c'est le par rapport à où vécut des deux
autres c'est celui qui va vieillir le
mieux s'il a un sang froid comment
s'appelle-t-il de shaolin voilà michael
collins est en train de charger et donc
ils vivent à il va il va il va pas
reconnaître les problèmes d'alcool de
besoin d'ailleurs voilà justement parce
que vous racontez ça ça aussi on le sait
peu de buzz aldrin puisqu'on le voit la
buzz aldrin il vit très mal son retour
sur l'histoire il avait des problèmes
d'alcool avant que il ya de famille
alcoolique donc il a caché ce défaut
parce que si on l'avait su unis serait
il serait jamais parti si vous donc
victime en illyrie l'aï vis très mal
d'être le deuxième homme qu'on ne parle
pas de lui ses parents aussi fin de
toute sa famille trouve insupportable
qu'on mette neil amstrong neil armstrong
comme ça en une des journaux et le vis
très mal et donc il va sombrer dans
l'alcoolisme et il va quitter la nasa et
devenir vendeur de cadillac que vous
imaginez c'est ça c'est en fait il est
il divorce de sa femme à un accident de
voiture où il est un peu bourré la femme
dit c'est fini c'est fini maintenant je
divorce enfin il a vraiment une une vie
totalement car ils deviennent des
vendeurs de voitures à l'hosto jim vous
imaginez vous allez acheter une cadillac
vous tombez sur buzz aldrin vous aimez
qu'est ce que tu fais là les gens
croyaient qu'ils faisaient une
démonstration que c'est une caméra
cachée ben non je vendais cadillac
c'était un copain il n'avait plus un
rond il était il à était endetté
jusqu'aux yeux et donc il a il est comme
ça et il va remonter la pente quand même
il va quitter va sortir de l'alcool il
va rester à revenir un petit peu dans le
jeu dans le jeu il va faire des unes de
journaux avec d'autres modes d'autres
astronautes et donc il va réussir à s'en
sortir mais les métaux et neil armstrong
il l'a mal vécu c'est lui apprend il
s'enferme lui il est autiste il
s'enferme dans son palais l'art il
pourchasse un moment donné poursuit en
justice son coiffeur que quelqu'un qui
vend des mèche de ses cheveux mais ils
essayent de v2
ils essaient de il a appelé à une amie
en justice il appuie la milady déteste
qu'on utilise sa phrase la fameuse
phrase vous savez c'est un gros poids là
ils détestent qu'on utilise donc il
essaie de l'ags la sauvegarde et faire
des procès ils essaient de sauvegarder
un petit peu son truc qui dit qu'il veut
plus monter là haut parce qu'il veut pas
qu'on 11 on ne veut pas qu'on abîme les
plaies voulait créer personnes malades
homme ne m'ont pas partir plus
chaleureux sur l mal arrive plus
personne ne monte pour commencer on
préserve c'est pas c'est pas divin sur
la sur la trace lunaire là ce qu'on
appelle là et roll it un peu cette
espèce de sable un peu gris kekel un peu
la surface lunaire il ne veut pas qu'on
abîme un petit peu le passage illustre
de monsieur amstrong donc il est laid
quand même dans une forme de folie et de
et de daim gris mais bon il s'enferme
mais il va quand même réussir à ne pas
te manque totalement tomber dans la
folie et finalement mourir de sa belle
mort bien plus tard
évidemment quand on l'est on les regarde
tous
au fond ça ressemble à une folie quand
même on est allé sur la lune on ya cru
on a cessé d'y aller et aujourd'hui on
n'est même pas sûr d'en être capable d'y
retourner non voyants n'est pas sûr
parce que à un moment donné les ça
n'intéressait plus grand monde si vous
voulez moi j'ai j'ai j'ai vu une
interview de charles duke un monde et
sur le cellulaire l'un des derniers
astronautes à être partis plus personne
ne s'intéresse à plus de caméras il ya
plus de 6 cm c'est absolument incroyable
du départ de la fusée et eux ils sautent
ils font les cons sur la lune et moment
donné il ya le cap canaveral qui disent
bon arrêtez vous rentrez maintenant
arrêter de fermer parce que le charles
duke sautent ils tombent il fait défiler
il fait l'imbécile com qu'est-ce que
j'ai mis comme des enfants qui refusent
de sortir de la piscine on ne prend plus
au sérieux ce voyage fabuleux
effectivement les gens en ont marre ils
vont arrêter cette cette équipe ça coûte
trop cher il ya toujours eu des
critiques sur la conquête spatiale y
avait il y avait des musiciens qui
disait que c'était un truc de blanc des
musiciens noirs qui trouvait que c'était
vraiment un caprice pour les blancs
c'était deal scott-heron voilà gil
scott-heron que ni le talent et sur la
lune voilà un autre master
avec des rares thèmes de sa chanson des
white the
forbidden mais il ya toute la vague
aussi qu'ils devaient à un moment où on
va dire bof ou tout ça n'a jamais existé
c'est un mensonge à 30 milliards de
dollars et vous raconter d'ailleurs que
buzz aldrin à montrant football à l'inde
et là des complotistes des complots dit
qu'il suit partout en disant de jure sur
la bible que vous êtes vraiment aller
sur la lune et besogne quand même assez
costaud on a eu tous une grande une
claque gigantesque les gens croyaient fa
les complotistes croyait que ce voyage
avait été tourné par stanley kubrick
dans des studios en californie certains
gros comme ça certains croient encore
donc il ya eu ils ont dû se défendre
contre 7 quand ce problème là et ça a
été ça a été douloureux en plus pour
buzz a dream qui vraiment a déjà vu me
supportait mal le retour mais en plus il
a dû supporter les complotistes les
femmes vont finir par aller sur la lune
enfin pas parler sur la lune mais aller
dans l'espace il ya l'histoire de cette
institutrice qui va mourir dans
l'explosion de la navette ça c'est un
drame terrible parce que pour la
première fois quelqu'un au civil pour
ainsi dire est envoyé dans l'espace il
ya toute sa classe tous les enfants des
états unis qui la regardent pas ce que
c'est une institutrice et elmer oui elle
meurt il y avait une seule ride aussi
vrai talent et homosexuels mais aussi et
elle avait été j'ai oublié le nom de
l'institutrice qui est morte on avait
trouvé d'ailleurs un poster de tom
selleck dans sa danse la danse a dans sa
loge j'ai mis ça parce que je trouvais
que c'était ces femmes qui sont quand
même extraordinaire ça reste aussi des
midinettes finalement qui aiment des
acteurs et donc celle je trouvais ça
assez douloureux finalement de montrer
un petit peu une petite passion
finalement deux gamines alors qu'elle
est elle a fait un entraînement
absolument incroyable pour monter dans
cette fusée est l'art et la salle i ride
en question est les homosexuels elle
cache qu'elle est homosexuelle et quand
elle a un cancer et qu'elle meurt c'est
ça sa petite amie tam o'shaughnessy
qu'il finit par faire le coming out de
sa livraison nous étions ensemble nous
étions amoureuses l'une de l'autre et
c'était deux grandes joueuses de tennis
en plus ça les bras il aurait pu choisir
de devenir joueuse de tennis
professionnelle mais elle a préféré la
conquête spatiale à roland garros quoi
vous me le donne aujourd'hui on le sait
des milliardaires américains
permettent que l'on puisse commencer à
véritablement faire du tourisme spatial
pour l'instant on n'a pas encore le ya
pas de ce côté cette saga non parce que
important c'est quand même
extraordinaire oui c'est extraordinaire
il ya encore six lycées critique encore
mon convoi roux et le must richard
branson on les accuse de dépenser de
l'argent inutilement de faire des petits
sauts de plus comme ça en l'air qui ne
serviront pas forcément la science
humaine donc il n'ya pas fictivement au
pis et on en train de banaliser un petit
peu cette ce cette merveille qu'est tech
et et la conquête spatiale la patrie ou
non va pas très lourd est pas très
longtemps entre on reste quelques
secondes on flotte un peu puis après on
redescend mais enfin j'ai entendu quand
même une interview quelques idées mais
décoller c'est très dangereux c'est
quand même ils peuvent très bien mourir
et les gens ne se rendent plus compte
que le décollage on est assis sur une
bombe une bombe volante et qu' elle peut
exploser donc finalement n'a perdu la
notion du danger du risque mais en
appréciant effectivement c'est que quand
on appelle ça le tourisme spatial c'est
un peu l'appareil photo en bandoulière
le short et on ne se rend plus compte un
petit peu de la gravité de 2 200 de ces
disciplines et stéphane koch la pensée
qu'on ira sur mars a je pense qu'on ira
sur mars on sera peut-être vous et moi
décédées depuis longtemps mais je pense
qu'on ira sur marcin moi j'avais déjà vu
le film de ridley scott je croise étape
les seuls sur mars n'était pas un très
bon film c'est un peu un bon film mais
sauf que personne ne peut croire une
histoire d'amour une histoire pareille
je pense qu'on ira sur mars mais bon il
reste que mars et qui n'habite table
donc qu'est-ce qu'on pourrait y faire là
bas je ne sais pas on pourra
effectivement tourné autour de mars
après il faudra inventer des du matériel
peut-être de playtex tout ce qu'on a
oublié de poussière folle sur mars
comment est ce qu'on est bien des gaz il
ya des gaz comment est-ce qu'on nettoie
sa combinaison il ya des toutes sortes
de problèmes pour aller surface et
encore plus pour y toucher il de
problèmes de santé puisque évidemment
c'est pas si un être humain peut rester
longtemps la hausse en choper le cancer
sans revenir totalement irradiés par les
rayons cosmiques
le docteur douglas avait raison la
conquête spatiale c'est la conquête
médical c'est que ça finalement c'est la
conquête du corps et quand on encore le
corps à trouver quand les médecins
auront trouvé une des protections pour
le corps des médicaments humains ou pour
aller très haut très loin mais ce qui
est intéressant dans votre livre c'est
qu'on voit que les premiers russe qui
pense à aller dans l'espace je pense
déjà à s'y installer c'est à dire que
comme comme d'une ce serait
vous citer la phrase la terre est le
berceau de l'humanité personne n'a envie
de finir sa vie dans son berceau de
regrets on a envie de partir et eux déjà
y penser aujourd'hui de nouveau certains
y pense c'est amusant de coloniser mars
ou d'autres planètes pour pouvoir ils y
pensent mes parents quand vous voyez la
femme sur la ligne de fritz lang ils
n'ont pas de combinaison il ou pas une
masse qui se baladent sur l une comme il
se baladerait dans un pré où veut pas
n'importe où c'est un vrai ça aussi dans
dans les importants né en 1920 voilà
dans les romans d'alger où elle c'est
pareil et on parlera pas plus le mot pas
de questions de combinaisons
recquis et c'est vraiment une balade de
santé pour eux donc évidemment il y
avait ce rêve là mais après dans les
années 20 30 ils ont commencé à
comprendre que ben il fallait s'habiller
en fonction est évident prendre ses
précautions et que c'était quelque chose
de dangereux et quel rôle a joué rg et
objectif lune et on a marché sur la lune
on est dans les années 50 là où tous des
buses et 50 et alors là en revanche ils
ont véritablement des des scaphandres il
ya la pesanteur il ya beaucoup de choses
hein berger reprend jules verne en fait
c'est à dire il reprend un peu le
fantasme de jules verne c'est vraiment
service se met dans les pas de jules
verne donc hergé n'apporte pas plus que
jules verne le grand le grand imagina et
le grand aux boîtes de la lune crs de
jules verne et salah c'est lui
finalement le grand inventeur de la
conquête spatiale mais
objectif lune et on a marché sur la lune
est plus proche de la réalité faut dire
aussi les plus proches aussi du moment
où on va y aller oui mais mais ce qui
est fascinant moi j'ai été à kourou l'as
olemps les fusées ariane c'est
exactement sur l'ambiance le d'objectif
lune il y aller oui parce qu'il avait il
ya les mêmes les mêmes contrôles les
mêmes parce que le 10 avions les mêmes
canon prêt à tirer au cadre d' attaque
il ya un loup tout est pareil parce que
hergé terrain documenté il s'est
documenté dans peu moins il lisait
beaucoup beaucoup d'essais beaucoup donc
évidemment il ay là il a réussi à
à lire il disait hermano berthe ils
pouvaient l'elysée robert goddard y
lisait tous tous ces gens il les connaît
ils connaissaient alors là leurs travaux
en jeu vient de bien sûr à jiwa soucis
donc il avait cette espèce de
documentation tous ses albums sont
extrêmement historiquement très fouillée
très documenté et très est très très
très vrai et en fait il a il a eu l'art
il a reçu des conseils il disait des
journaux donc il y avait il y avait chez
hergé quand même une absence de l'archi
de l'arche yves absolument incroyable
qu'est ce qui vous a donné envie
d'écrire cette histoire secrète vous
mais moi je les trouvais plutôt sur la
musique depuis j'ai écrit deux livres
sur le baron rouge ou dette donc si j'ai
j'adore l'aviation et je me disais j'ai
adoré agi ouest et j'ai adoré jules
verne aussi donc évidemment on a envie
un petit peu de participer un petit peu
récit de cette conquête spatiale et je
me dis ya encore des choses à raconter
que les gens ne connaissent pas des
personnages totalement rester dans
l'ombre et qui serait intéressant de
mettre en lumière et je me disais en
plus ils ont une porte une poésie tout
si tous ces gens là une porte à rouyn
côté romanesque absolument incroyable et
donc il y avait aussi le côté c'était un
s'était ainsi d'une histoire qui se
passe entre les camps de concentration
et les rêveries astral et la rêverie
astral et donc je trouvais très
intéressant ce mélange de guerre et de
poésie des étoiles voyez tout ce qui a
finalement parcouru du 20e siècle c'est
à dire que traverse l horrible avec
beaucoup de dictature deux camps de
concentration mais en même temps la
chose la plus merveilleuse le rêve qui
finalement fini par traverser et emporté
les l'être humain vers vers la lune mais
si stéphane gosselin et l'histoire
secrète de la conquête spatiale ça vient
de paraître aux éditions du rocher merci
de nous avoir suivis et rendez vous au
prochain numéro
[Musique]